[Music]
political loser for them they initiated
it they thought this is a great idea and
at least for the short term it has been
a colossal political mistake that was
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
earlier today pointing out that the
Schumer Chip sham show was a massive
strategic error for the Democrats it was
a waste of time and it has not helped
our country as leader McConnell's office
noted the Democrats threw the kitchen
sink at president Trump it ended in
nothing but a full acquittal for the
president joining us now he's also the
author of this is a great book about how
important our judiciary is and all the
judges that have gotten appointed thanks
to the hard work of senator Mitch
McConnell the Senate Majority Leader's
served
I watched today and I watched you
closely throughout this whole process
and you know you win again I'm not sick
of winning but I saw a party for three
years
angry unhinged they've done nothing for
the American people and they look
diminished and small and petty and
insignificant to me that's how I see
your the other side of the aisle your
thoughts I couldn't agree with you more
I mean the best evidence of that and
you've been talking about I'm sure for
24 hours is the speaker tearing up the
President's speech how childish and
petty is that what kind of example is
that set for the American people about
how we ought to conduct ourselves I mean
have we forgotten how to be civil to
each other particularly when we're in
Congress sit in together not out on the
campaign trail not at rallies but at
least among ourselves we ought to be
able to disagree and not behave like a
bunch of children you know a senator
even things that they supported in
Obama's second term like protecting our
borders where 90% of the heroin crosses
into this country once Donald Trump
proposed that they they didn't support
it you're in the middle of this how do
what tell us what you see what you
what you observe behind the scenes what
what is what is driving them well the
best evidence of it has been on display
the last two or three weeks the most
aggressive thing you can do to any
president is to try to impeach them and
they did it on a party-line boat and you
could best describe it as Trump
derangement syndrome in other words
whatever he's for they are just have a
Pavlovian negative response to it almost
immediately look I think the thing to
take away here and I said it in my press
conference today and I think you led
with it this was a thoroughly political
maneuver if it was it was stupid it
backfired the presidents got the best
numbers he's had since he's been in
office my members who were in tough
races are all looking at better numbers
than they were before impeachment
started so if this was all about the
November election it seems to me we can
conclude at least in the short term here
this was a colossal political mistake
one quick question about government
senator Romney I felt his his speech
today was almost incoherent to me in
this regard he just exonerated out of
nowhere Joe and Hunter Biden I'm not
looking for your thoughts on that and
then he goes into this long lengthy
argument
what are your thoughts about that one
vote of his today well I was surprised
and I was disappointed but my job is to
try to win as often as I can in the
Senate there's always the next vote
senator Romney on the whole has been
supportive of what we've been trying to
accomplish in the year these been there
I think this was a mistake I disagree
with it on the other hand we've got a
lot more votes to cast between now
November and I'm going to need his
support on a whole variety of things
that are important to the President and
to the country as the president listed
all of the economic success and foreign
policy success Soleimani Baghdadi the
Caliphate etc all the trade deals all
the new jobs created it's a pretty long
list senator that seems to me like if
you
ask the question are you better off than
you were four years ago the answer is an
overwhelming yes absolutely no question
people are better off now than they were
four years ago and I think that's the
central theme underlying the president's
fall campaign and he did a masterful job
last night of laying all this out
in front of the American people at a
time when a lot of them are tuning in
and paying attention and all the
Democrats were left with was sort of
pouting on the floor you know trying to
avoid any kind of positive response to
anything he said I thought it was
childish and silly and counterproductive
for them you know senator we appreciate
it
you won this battle like you won the
judge battle in the Cavanaugh battle the
president obviously is winning for the
country I'm not sick of winning senator
mcconnell's thank you for being with us
Thank You Sean